Moi c'est Servane, j'ai vingt-et-un ans,
j'suis étudiante en philosophie et en droit
et surtout, cette année, j'suis candidate aux élections
européennes pour le parti animaliste.
J'ai arrêté de manger des animaux
alors que j'étais très
très jeune, à partir du moment où
j'ai pu comprendre
que la viande n'était autre
qu'un animal qu'on avait dû abattre,
j'ai commencé à militer alors que j'avais 12 ans
dans différentes associations.
Donc d'aussirants que je me souvienne,
j'ai toujours eu à cœur La Défense des animaux
et j'ai toujours été animé
par la lutte contre l'injustice qu'on leur fait subir.
Parce que plus on se renseigne,
plus on se rend compte de l'horreur
que subisse les animaux
au quotidien.
On les utilise pour littéralement tout,
que ce soit pour se nourrir,
pour se vétir, voir même pour se divertir.
Mais en fait, on est nombreux
à être sensibles à la souffrance
que ressentent les plus vulnérables
et le parti animaliste est 1 moyen de montrer ça aux
prochaines élections.
Le parti animaliste est celui qui porte les
revendications d'une agriculture durable
et qui prend en compte les intérêts de
tous les êtres sensibles.
Mais ton silence étouffe leur souffrance.
Alors le neuf/06 prochain, aux élections européennes,
tu sais pour qui voter ?
Vote pour les animaux, vote pour le parti animaliste